[Applause]
Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas have made
their close bond official and we're
bringing you all the must know glamorous
details from their wedding weekend in
India
[Music]
[Applause]
to
the couple who confirm their engagement
in August after several months of dating
tied the knot on Saturday in Jodhpur
India in a Christian ceremony officiated
by Nick's father Paul Kevin Jonas senior
as for the bride's wedding day style
everything that I wear I have to be
comfortable and cute so it's gonna be
cute and comfortable she reportedly
opted for a stunning a Ralph Lauren gown
and the couple ended their unforgettable
day with an enormous fireworks display
over the palace I'm someone who's been
private about my personal life but like
when it happens in a big way I would
want the world home afterward the pair
both posted photos from the joyous
affair including this image of them
smiling together while surrounded by
friends and family at the mehndi another
Indian pre-party during which Priyanka
got traditional henna tattoos on her
palms and arms Priyanka captioned the
pics one of the most special things that
our relationship has given us is a
merging of families who love and respect
each other's faiths and cultures I'm
very excited and on Sunday the 36 year
old bride instagrammed this professional
video and a series of pics from the
couple's traditional Indian Sangeeth
ceremony which took place on Friday what
a performance
it was each family telling our stories
through song and dance filled with lots
of laughter and love we were both filled
with gratitude for the effort she
captioned the post which showcased the
night of music and dancing Nick's older
brother Joe Jonas was one of the
participants even the bride and groom
put their best dance moves on display in
front of a clapping crowd the couple
also enjoyed a puja ceremony which took
place at Chopra's mother's home earlier
in the week as well as a holiday
ceremony to ward off evil and shower the
couple with blessings I think if you
care about somebody there's nothing
wrong in making
one feel as special as you feel like
they are in your heart now Priyanka and
Nick will complete their multi-day
wedding festivities with a Hindu
marriage ceremony on Sunday but before
they say I do for a second time
according to Priyanka's insta stories
team bride took on Team groom for a
friendly game of cricket this is such a
wonderful new step in my life we have no
doubt these two are the real deal when
et caught up with Priyanka in October
she couldn't help but gush about her man
I haven't seen myself happier and just
being in the whole situation of finding
somebody who can be a partner to you in
so many ways than one is amazing
[Music]